so allergic to this now what this is
going to do is it's going to connect us
back to the trig calculus we were doing
I think in the last term okay if that we
just sort of remember if you recall we
were tried to a Jeb everything we were
like ah we're sort of a little bit ahead
of schedule
cocktail secrete boxes was not included
in the AP 3 but we made sure before then
because it's kind of like yeah we're uh
we're here wait so therefore let's do it
there but like we're all conscious yet
number one it wasn't going to be a bad
system period number two like it's a big
it's a big topic as you can see it
connects a huge amount all will be doing
now so there's actually one little thing
that I left off the end we just ran out
of time before you stand exist and this
was it now we're going to meet it in the
context of what we're doing this week
which is the kind of function that comes
out when you integrate this but we're
also going to go back to just regular
trig functions so let's have a look at
this now revised with me why do you
reference it right there are two
quotable results or something like that
to do with slightly vegetated mr.
meadows so what are the actual results
pause okay let's think about this so
here time best memory ever okay now
which what is this where is this come
from because one of them has a square
root and the other one does
yes okay no good now it's always you
guys don't need to worry about this
because you have a reference sheet in
front of you however I talked before
that fat buddy really this referee is
not designed for me this reference sheet
is not designed for you I would not
expect that most of you would use your
reference sheet in any sort of extensive
way do you think my clients on it and
it's kind of lights there as a safety
blanket but there's a time penalty that
is incurred by anyone who uses the
reference tree and you guys don't need
to buy the time that you've used these a
lot like we're just at the beginning
really much possibilities that you can
look at that and say straight away okay
yeah I just want to call you back to for
those poor people who didn't have a
reverse eight even though this photo
actually the stuff was on there for
those people who really you know we
would remember this I want to know why
this one is this one is this my plan for
me the square root rather than the site
is the hopeful way to remember which one
is which why did a square root appear or
the denominator when we were doing one
of the investor equals it was from the
you're gonna cost squared but actually
you wanted a cause there right so you
had to take the square root we're to do
with the domain there and say why is it
that wasn't case not related case and so
on so that's the way I remember that the
top one of course is it was because
that's where when you do side that's
what gives you cause and that's why
you're gonna take square root whereas
when you're doing the bottom one it's
and the reason why is because what
identity did we take advantage of in
this case what was Ted squared is equal
to sec sweat which that by itself that
there's the derivative tense that's why
we didn't need to appeal to any
subscriber
okay alright so when you look over there
which of those two is this closer to
it's clearly closer to the square root
right this is completely different and
there's a pot as well which is another
difference however this is not in the
form that I wanted to be is it what am I
gonna need to do with that
we're already
somewhere close to here yeah okay so I
could take it out of for right now
interesting we though it might take out
a form that's gonna become one over for
the visit to out the front so that
becomes my because my a square and then
I'll just have x squared there okay so
that's fine this approach what it's
saying is I don't want this to be 4x
squared I just want it to be regular x
squared so let's just drop down so that
we all have this thing up here is is one
way with the deuce would I take a factor
of four out a factor of four underneath
the square is actually a factor of two
outside the square root because it's the
square root of four manages to so if I
pop it to at the furthest square root
and this becomes this like so are you
happy with that
do you see what I've done before I could
have put an extra step this my suppose
but now I have looked at two a squared
by this X square I mean this is nicely
convenient a quarter is an easy square
to work out but it could be anything it
could be a third and you just be taking
the square root what it's me 103 right
but in this case it's nice and neat so I
look at this and I say AHA there's a 1/2
all the way out the front and everything
that remains fits exactly into that
first view right so I'm going to have
sine inverse of now I could write 2x
that's why it's correct just for my own
sake because I'll get confused at work
there like dividing about what place /
I'll actually gonna write x over a which
is 1/2 right
which of course is going to give me the
chance